hi there steve kaufman here steve
kaufman of link as you know and uh of my
blog the linguist on language
and today i want to talk about um two
things
first of all uh how important is it that
companies that have language learning
systems on the web
should be managed by people with a
formal background in language education
and second of all how do we evaluate
a learner
best and how do we evaluate whether a
program
a school or a language learning program
is affected the reason i want to talk
about this is because i have been
involved in a discussion over at kirsten
winkler's blog and i will put the
link here in the description to this
video
where someone posted saying that
people on the internet who are signing
up for these language learning programs
like live moca itake
busu
link and so forth
should be wary
because the people who run these aren't
using uh
you know experts with a proper
educational background in language
education
so that was the one point and then as i
got involved in the discussion there it
became clear that the two people on that
uh discussion uh felt very strongly that
that there had to be some kind of
objective evaluation of how effectively
people are learning
whereas i took the position that if the
learner is satisfied with his or her
progress that is really the best
uh indication now
i don't know why i get involved in these
discussions
must be because
i went skiing and came back early and my
wife went golfing
so i look at these things and i'm always
interested in
in discussions about language learning
and it came through on
linkedin where i'm a member of a group
which is called some kind of language
learning group
so i saw a reference to this discussion
and of course as usual i jumped in with
both feet
um but
to me first of all
language resources on the internet are
not schools
they are just that they are resources
uh italki is a place where you can go
and find language partners
rhino spike is a place where you can
have
any text recorded by a native speaker
link is linked as you know i believe
very much in input based language
learning and you'll find lots of
resources that will help you
access content and use audio and text
content for your language learning their
resources that's what they are
some of them are developed i would say a
lot of them actually are developed by
keen language learners
but not necessarily by people with an
educational background in
in pedagogy
does it matter of course it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter at all
and people need not be wary any more
than they're wary walking into a store
they are users
they are potential customers
they can come and look around and
in the case of link they can use it free
of charge and then decide if they want
to stay or if they want to pay for
certain additional services that cost
money or
they can download content free of charge
and take it away and do whatever they
want
so
i think it's tremendous that there are
these entrepreneurs
on the internet and also in terms of
apps
in ipod or the iphone that are creating
products for learners
and the learner can decide to buy not to
buy to stay most of them realize that on
the internet you have to offer a lot for
free in order to get people
uh to uh to use it because there's so
much stuff there it's great
it it for the first time the learner
is is treated like like a customer like
someone with some the right to choose
whereas in the average school that's not
the case
i think in most schools this the learner
is quite captive
because they have to sign up for a
semester or for a year for four years
typically they are paid for by someone
else might be in the case of immigrants
it might be the government that's
subsidizing them it might be their
parents
or someone else they might be sent there
by their employer there's so many
different situations where the learner
is just captive and so therefore the
teacher and the the person who runs the
school is free to do what they want
some of which may be very very good but
the decision very much
is with the teacher
uh so that's fine that's perhaps the by
far the largest part of the market
that's fine maybe that'll always be the
case but why would
someone not the fact that there is now
choice by the internet
that entrepreneurs such as me
i don't know if i call myself an
entrepreneur as much as
don quixote tilting at windmills but
nevertheless we put things up there
and people come and sniff and have a
look and they choose
and some do well and some don't so
to me the question of educational
background is completely irrelevant
the second issue was you know i said
it sort of challenged me well how do you
know that your learners at link are
doing well and i say because they tell
me if they're happy if they're happy
they stay if they're not happy they go
uh
and when we get testimonials from people
saying that they've never had
so much success learning languages
before that they're very happy with link
some of them say that they've
increased their score on toeic by our
many marks and that they attribute this
to link and so we get a lot of positive
feedback
very some almost our heart warming
notes of thank you from people that's
enough
um so to which the response is well
that's you know the satisfaction of the
learner is not sufficient we need an
objective evaluation well
uh of course people who want to go
to take a third party test are quite
welcome to do so and many of our
learners have done so
uh
personally if i learn language i have no
interest in having someone else evaluate
how well i'm doing in the language i
know when i understand i know when i can
communicate i know if i do better now
than i did six months ago that sense of
satisfaction achievement and progress
that i myself feel is all i need but i
recognize that for different purposes
people need some kind of a certificate
and i think that those kinds of uh
you know call it objective it's not
really objective but somewhat objective
testimony or proof of someone's level or
progress in the language they should be
done by
arms length independent testing
organizations schools should not be
handing out diplomas because that's the
other problem people go to a school in
order to get the diploma
uh so that the school controls so they
have to go through the school to get the
diploma well it shouldn't be that way i
should be able to go
and sit any exam i want in to test my
language competence and i would take it
further even in other fields
say particularly in terms of
universities and in terms of history or
literature or whatever if i can do the
test but staying with languages for now
if i can take the toeic is a good
example it's a great test
sixty dollars whatever it costs i take
the toeic it doesn't matter whether i
studied on my own whether i studied at
some institution it shouldn't matter you
know we shouldn't have a situation where
these diplomas that testify to your
language competence are issued by the
same places that are
asking you to pay money to learn there
uh in the case of link nothing prevents
people from going to a third party
to have their competence tested every
six months so that they can evaluate how
well they're doing at length but i don't
think it's up to link to do that as far
as i'm concerned it's it's almost like a
gym you know we offer facilities uh we
listen to our customers they say we want
this we want that we try to respond to
what we think is a widespread need we
want to provide a better and better
facility resource for people to use as
part of their language learning
experience and the same is true of
italki and busu and live mocha and all
these people and the learner now is put
in the position that they haven't
enjoyed before of being able to choose
so they can choose to spend time in live
mocha they can choose to spend time at
link in conjunction with perhaps going
to a school and they have much more
choice
so
i mean the conclusion to me is i think
that the the learner is the best judge
of how well they're doing i think in
most cases but many people want for a
variety of reasons personal or
professional to get a third party
evaluation go and get it from toeic or
from cambridge or from wherever
but
i don't feel that at link i'm
responsible for the results of my
learners
i'm responsible for creating the best
possible learning community environment
system we're constantly thinking up new
things that might be helpful
what the learners do with that is up to
the learners that's part and parcel of
being an independent learner is that you
go out and find the resources that suit
you
and you are responsible for your
learning
uh and we are responsible for having a
high quality uh facility now then they
come back well how do you know that your
facility is high quality unless it's
been you know vetted by again by some
board of people with
with uh you know educational credentials
well i've had enough experience with
those people to know that anything that
doesn't fit
their perception
that you know that tutors have to be
credentialed and that you have to follow
some theory that's been uh
you know as part of the the language
teaching orthodoxy and so forth that
they will simply discount what you're
doing
but i say like
can listening be bad can reading be bad
can building up your vocabulary be bad
and talking to native speakers be bad is
there anything we do at length that is
not a big part of language learning i
mean people can also learn
just by talking with people that why
does language learning have to it's not
like we're not running an engineering
school here it's all about
learning to do something that's actually
quite natural
uh
yeah so
i know i'm allowed to go to 15 so i'll
now i'll save it i'll save it for the
this other issue that i had a chat with
susannah
zareiske i hope i got it right
unfortunately our our skype conversation
was got frozen so i don't know if we're
going to put it up or not
but this whole issue of
of when should we start
speaking
and um
yeah i think i have a conversation
planned with with robert of austria on
that subject so i'll save my my views on
that
for that conversation so you may be
seeing some of these uh video exchanges
skype exchanges if we can get through
the technology at any rate uh thank you
for listening and if you're wondering
why i'm bouncing up and down is because
i'm sitting on a ball here one of these
medicine balls and it's kind of good i
like i like sitting on them also i had a
great day skiing today it was a
wonderful day here in vancouver
so thank you for listening bye for now